you'd watch the Emmys last night who
here so you see some of the Emmys okay
all right
yeah the Emmys were last night and there
was no host did you know that there was
no host yeah no no that's fine but
people keep suggesting I do this show
without a host I find that very hurtful
you and if Andy is the one who keeps
bringing it up if you're not here I
don't have to be here yeah it's the
guest and let him do selfies per hassle
okay yeah some think it's just gonna be
a speakerphone over there what's going
on not a lot of people I mean you could
kind of tell when I asked the crowd a
lot of people did not apply the Emmys
last night watched by a record low
number of 7 million people only 7
million people watch the Emmys yeah yeah
and 1 million of those were Game of
Thrones cast members
[Laughter]
and those were the alive ones these
streaming platforms did very well last
night 27 Emmys for Netflix seven Emmys
for Amazon and three Emmys for Zappos
the online thank you we have three three
people in the crowd who give a [ __ ]
about Zappos thank God for you three
that's checkout their shoes yeah I know
the Emmys in memoriam section you know
where we say goodbye to people
accidentally broadcast a photo of a
person who's not dead yet
yes yeah today the producers apologized
profusely to Bernie Sanders stunningly
accurate impression he's getting real
raspy now too
yeah just staring me down it's getting
creepy